this afternoon approximately 5 10 the
911 Center received multiple calls from
the Seattle Vista Molly in reference to
shots fired possible active shooter
multiple units responded from the
Apostle police department and attempted
to locate the shooter at this time we do
have four persons that were injured or
shot during this incident we can confirm
one person has deceased and the other
three have been transported to local
hospitals right now we don't have any
more information on the injured like I
said earlier we have a total four were
shot
inside the mall uh
we think at the approximate area of the
food court but that's not confirmed at
this time right now initial reports and
this is all preliminary that the the
suspect was taken into custody inside
the mall very shortly after the incident
began